often wins
yeah uh jordan is a bit of a bogey
player for uh anish he's the kryptonite
uh if we look back i think in a dutch
championship jordan won once uh in
vikanze jordan won the title by beating
anish in a play-off in a blitz playoffs
so um if we do go down to playoffs
jordan has four memories also this year
in vikanze jordan won a beautiful game
ivanka referenced it earlier
so recent history is definitely in
jordan's favor
and uh okay
simon how happy are you it's the berlin
defense
you know um at least he's played this
interesting move well jordan has of
keeping the queens on the board and
the these middle games do do actually
get very exciting as we saw in eric
hanson he had this position as white
against jordan with the black pieces i
think a couple of days ago and uh that
was that was chaotic everywhere so this
is one of the more interesting uh berlin
lines in in in my view anyway
and uh yeah this knight move by jordan
not the most common and it's actually
well known to lead to a forced draw so
i'm hoping that we don't see black's
knight uh leap into the center of the
board to the d4 square okay we do see
that
oh dear this leads to a lot of trades a
lot of exchanges it depends what jordan
does though on the next few moves i'm
expecting him to take that night off the
board first
we kind of reference that uh jordan as
somewhat a tricky player for anish to
handle
i mean
how do you also play against those
opponents where you have a really bad
score against
well i'm sitting next to one of them at
least
definitely how do i play i think you've
got to just
it's very psychological you've got to
try to uh pump yourself up and say this
is going to be the game i'm going to
break that record and uh you know it can
affect you but it can also be a good
thing because uh you know it gives you
that extra um oomph to uh to try and win
yeah and often once you break the record
um i mean for example i always struggle
against luke well i used to struggle at
least against luke mcshane strong
english grandmaster and he beat me
several times in big big matches but
once i got a one win i started a streak
and yeah it's just about that
psychological aspect as you mentioned
simon not fearing the opponent playing
the board not uh
not uh that guy you struggle against and
okay meanwhile a lot has happened there
have been a set of trades a set of
knights left the board a bishop for a
night trade black has a bit of a weird
wacky pawn structure on that left side
double d pawns but that is compensated
for by the bishop pair
and uh still very well known territory
here is this this is the drawing line
because to my eyes i mean i don't know
this variation it actually looks quite
interesting it does because until you
analyze it with the computers oh okay
because it you know it looks like
there's a very unsymmetrical position
there's two bishops there's a bishop at
night so it's okay a bit disappointing
but they both want to just get into the
playoffs i guess and play blitz chess so
yeah that's right we'll see what black
does here there are a few moves uh black
can just push a pawn in the center
and uh yeah there are some kind of ways
to keep playing uh i'm not sure exactly
what jordan has in mind anish meanwhile
making a bit of a face there kind of
just putting out his bottom lip being
like
what are you going to try mate yes but
yeah this last pawn push very very solid
and
yeah maybe i'm a bit harsh saying force
draw there are some ways to keep it
alive but now black does have an idea of
bringing out black's light square bishop
to pin the white knight if you can hit
that white knight even trade it off
as we're about to see we're heading to
quieter waters uh anish not too
impressed as he keeps making that face
i'm not impressed either unfortunately
now you can just take off uh the white
knight from the board um i'm pretty sure
i've seen i studied this just a couple
of months ago i can understand why
jordan's done this though because he has
great memories of beating a niche uh you
know in this the wimbledon of chess they
call it the
waikanzi competition in the playoffs the
blitz game and maybe looking at anisha's
blitz play yesterday when he played
against duda it wasn't his normal
standard so he might be doing this just
as a tactical ploy right i'm going to
get him into the blitz and concentrate
all my um all my forces in that yeah it
makes sense as well from a tournament
standing uh if this match is uh drawn
two two you do secure yourself one point
uh in the tournament rather than losing
in the rapids where you get zero points
they secure themselves a bit of money as
well if this is one it's a draw but
obviously not going for the maximum
three points if they win in the rapid
portion
so yeah uh solid very solid approach by
jordan but anish as long as he knows his
stuff he's surely studied this before uh
he should be able to hold the draw okay
pushing a pawn this is the other way
this is the other myth but i was going
to say something you know i had uh
breakfast with jordan and he told me he
actually preferred classical chess
rather than this uh blitz fast and
furious style you know because there he
had time to think he had time to
navigate all the complexities that often
he's initiated in the opening
so i'm a little bit
surprised he didn't put a niche
a bit more under the
under pressure
yeah well i mean i to me it still seems
like there's a lot of play so i'm kind
of surprised this is a you know look at
those pawns how can this be a dead draw
when you got there for a second you had
three pawns yeah this is so primarily
you had triple pawns
they're so cool is that that's just
pretty rare it's pretty rare to get the
triple pawns they're they're actually so
called the irish pawns because uh a
couple of irish players in the olympiad
uh had that pawn structure and they
named it after that so uh yeah not
because they look drunk
no no no no no
have you i i heard the story was that
there was an irish player who had them
once in a game and he lost and then his
opponent had them the next game jonathan
spillman and he lost again so it was
like named after him aiming keown
but um i i don't know the true fit i
mean they do kind of look like drunken
pawns as well don't they when they're
all guinness pawns yeah yeah
is this still is this still theory david
because um
yes i'm sure about the last move but
ivanka's got
kind of
looking at it and i'm saying okay yep
this was analyzed in
2018. yep so now if i can recall
correctly black can just use the black
rook come down to the second rank and
capture a pawn defend the black queen uh
okay there we go uh the reason i pause
is because normally black had flicked in
bishop takes knight first uh just just
to trade and get rid of white tonight
because now with this imbalance maybe
there's some chances the queen and
knight a great attacking combo queen and
bishop may be less flexible i just can't
see how this is a draw i mean it looks
it looks so unbalanced here but you
should have taken the night yeah i think
anisha could have taken the knight and
that's okay i mean i say force draw but
at the top level it should be a draw uh
if the bushman knight just disappeared
from the board there's just not enough
pawns left but a not trading that night
off yeah interesting today is the 25th
of april right because i during
chestnuts i tend to lose track of the
date so i'm just looking at
when this analysis was done it was
actually april 21st
2022 just a few days ago
so maybe jordan has found some way to uh
keep the pressure on in this line which
is considered draw i mean jordan's
always finding very interesting ways to
find little you know little just small
differences in well-known openings i
mean but now david as you point out this
night move uh white has a number of
threats here's material and balance
black has extra porn but um there's a
lot going on i think there is a lot
going on and just the speed with which
jordan kind of put the white knight on
the edge of the board
shows to me that he's still in
preparation and wow okay maybe still in
preparation now he's attacking the black
bishop i don't know if that black bishop
is going to move though because if it
does move it might be danger for anish
giri
let's just jump in and show what's
happening this night move that we
highlighted getting out of the way not
allowing a trade and now after the black
queen jumped back we saw the pawn push
forward attacking the white attacking
the black bishop and as mentioned it
shouldn't move and this is a recurring
theme of the day the knight and f5 is
actually going to win the game for white
uh the queen and knight teaming up
together and therefore anish said okay i
i don't care about my bishop it's more
important to get rid of your knight and
uh after a trade the bishop disappearing
the night disappearing now jordan again
weird move uh not taking this pawn which
looks like it's up for grabs not taking
this pawn uh which looks like it's up
for grabs instead just moving his queen
forward once hi
uh i i'm struggling
to understand that one i guess he's
going for this pawn but is it or is he
trying to swing the rook around if black
takes the pawn potentially
he's obviously in prep because you would
not move this quickly unless you've
looked at this position beforehand um i
mean i always wonder david i mean you
might have had experience this like the
world championships jordan was one of
magnus carlson's seconds
are you allowed to play the preparation
that you that you've actually uh
prepared for the world championships or
or you are you not allowed to play it is
it like is it like magnus carlsen's prep
now because he's paying you to be a
second or can you
play it i don't know what's what i
assume that you know
the prep that you cover yeah it's uh
private private yeah yeah
keep
keep it that way yes yeah and there's
actually some
relatively well publicized tension
because of course jordan was aneesh uh
anish giri's second for a long long time
for many years they worked together and
then jordan kind of helped out magnus at
the world championship and now it's
unclear um what the future is uh in that
anishigiri podcast that we discussed
anish made it clear that he was
not entirely happy with some stuff that
had gone on and some uh kind of
contractual
obligations right so absolutely it was a
very long contract about what could be
revealed what couldn't be discussed
because it's hard for niche now to start
working with jordan again because jordan
is
sort of he has to hide some stuff yeah
it's uh it's hard normally once you pick
a team you stick with that team but now
jordan he's timonishi's team magnus it's
uh
it's difficult and yeah a lot of gray
area in terms of what openings they've
discussed together what
can be shared what can't be shared i
think there's been some famous cases in
the past uh in world championship
matches even where one one person has
got the notes or one player has sold it
to the other player even or given it to
the other player which is really
controversial because that would make
the world a difference if you're you
know setting off notes and i mean it's
probably not legally any binding but
morally uh it's incredibly uh dubious so
yeah and on a recent kind of case i mean
obviously um
rustam kasimajanov has stopped working
with fabiana caruana so risdan was his
long time second and he kind of likened
the separation to some kind of divorce
and their analysis were the children and
they were working out you know what kind
of access that's a nice way to put it
the children yeah it's a nice way yeah
yeah yeah it's um it's quite a touchy
subject then i guess i mean like you
know very very yeah
who knows what the right answer is but i
think you've got to have some moral
obligation not to give away those
secrets as well
yeah i was listening while you were
recording the podcast and and uh and she
did talk quite openly about it actually
yeah exactly i mean he was very frank
very honest and open um he did as well
say that jordan good friend always will
be uh jordan has a lot of integrity so
of course he won't
kind of play both sides or reveal too
much but it's tricky sometimes things
accidentally come out right you can't
help it uh when you discuss chests
together um i'm unsure whether they've
discussed an opening like this together
for example whether jordan looked at it
with a niche or with magnus or
who knows but either way i mean it's
moved 24 now in this game and this is
the type of opening that you could have
discussed at some point it's very
critical very main line and remember all
i'm going to call it drama
is available in that podcast it's
released today on chess24.com collection
site or anywhere that you listen to your
podcasts anish geary talking about all
of this
the drama i'm going to call it the drama
with jordan van furis then magnus's team
for the world championship match okay
and uh a lot of drama of course uh
behind those stories in the podcast in
recent months for anisha you were gonna
say a lot of drama in the game i was
gonna say a lot of drama there but less
in the game okay a little bit however
because white now with this last pawn
push has solidified all of his pawns on
the right half of the board and now the
white queen is ready to go hunting and
uh maybe ready to grab some pawns black
is temporarily a pawn up that's why
anish finds
well at least uh tries to defend his
extra pawn but is this one surprising
white can push a central pawn forward
now
on the d line there's a lot of tension
there's a pin
can white get greedy that is the
question and try to restore material
balance yeah i was thinking you know
maybe the black queen can try to jump in
to those weak and dark squares if that
if that is played but yeah you're right
dave this is certainly the the critical
move just uh if you can play one more
move and get an incredibly strong pass
pawn uh on that square there then you
must be doing very well
so actually you know niche nils still
needs to overcome some problems here
there's definitely a niche on the back
foot um despite knowing lots of opening
uh theory despite not spending much time
and getting to move 25 if jordan pushes
his pawn forward anisha is the one who
has to prove that he can make the draw
um as you mentioned simon maybe that
involves jumping forward with the queen
uh because remember you can't take this
pawn the black rook falls behind it the
white rook and queen now teaming up to
win a piece um so yeah maybe the idea is
to bring the black queen forward maybe
hinting at some nasty checks on the dark
squares or maybe after pawn takes pawn
simply trading queens i'm not sure this
becomes a pawn race now whether black
can just step the pawn forward and
bring the king towards winning white's
very strong pawn maybe black's in time
to do this it's uh it's not quite clear
so
a lot of calculation need to be needs to
be done especially if you consider any
queen trades in the position and that's
why jordan is pausing because if he
pushes his pawn forward it becomes very
very complicated or very at least hard
to calculate
yeah i actually rejected that paul move
on the basis of that queen trade because
it looked to me that white was a little
bit too slow
um but then if white doesn't push that
pawn forward
what earth is quite gonna do you know
move the key i mean everything else is
like primed yeah i mean you can maybe
move the king towards the center i don't
see how it helps at all no um you know
you might open yourself up to some
checks um this is probably why the
position is is you know still
roughly balanced yeah um you could just
wait you could push a pawn okay he's
going for it though jordan he couldn't
find anything else and look at anish
suddenly he's calculating what happens
if he brings his queen forward as we
mentioned potentially trading or
potentially jumping in with a check
yeah that amazing like that immediate
change of body language from a niche
shows that he's uh in calculation
haven't you said that when he puts his
head in his hands
usually he's not too happy not too happy
at all yeah i mean here obviously he's
not losing his black but he's the one
trying to force the draw trying to
survive
white is the one playing for the
advantage still despite what the
computer says uh the onus the pressure
is on black to still draw this game yeah
i mean maybe after the queen does come
in white can still shift the king one
square if that helps but i think this is
you know still going to head towards the
draw most likely this this this line but
i can't understand why jordan's playing
this way because uh you know
as you mentioned yeah it's risk-free and
anisha's got to find the right defensive
moves to to get that draw if he doesn't
then it could be in some problems so
yeah that's modern chess theory right
most openings have been considered to be
fine because of computers but often you
just test your opponent's memory or test
their calculation or something if they
calculate well if they remember
everything okay a draw is not the end of
the world
especially in one-on-one knockout
matches
like this definitely not end of the
world it's a start of
the blitz tie breaks which would be
super cool to see between these two
players in each gary he has some great
experience from blitz thai breaks
beating hikaru nakamura in the tour
finals last season specifically i
remember
how about jordan how would he be in
blitz thai breaks well he has a very
good uh opening repertoire you know it's
tricky it's dangerous and uh we do have
a move from anish that's clever it is a
very clever idea so the whole point is
that after pawn takes pawn the queen
will just dive back down give a check
and it will be something known as
perpetual check the king just cannot
escape these checks yeah so as mentioned
pawn takes pawn there by ivanka what
else if you take with the queen then
black can simply take your pawn and
black's actually temporarily a pawn up
white can grab the pawn back but it's
just too symmetrical this will for sure
end in a draw so if jordan wants to win
then he has to play pawn takes pawn and
you mentioned this jack ivanka if the
white king goes to the side then you can
give another check with the queen now
that you are defended with your rook and
another check if you go forward however
how do we make the drawers black i guess
you go back this way with a check if
white goes back of course you can
continue checking however if white goes
forward it's the idea to try and deliver
checkmate push a pawn and try to trap
this white king
that looks dangerous i was thinking of
also just checking along the diagonal
okay checking on the diagonal with the
queen here
and uh yeah actually it just looks too
risky for white to play for the win by
marching the king up the board
uh it's possible however maybe
uh maybe here you can give another check
if you really need to get back to your
line unless or then we'll have to look
at your line
yeah and uh for example this is what the
players are calculating whether white
can get away with running out into the
open with his king
he doesn't look like it wouldn't touch
it with a barge power as we say no this
would be a horrible way to lose as well
i mean but you've got to check these
lines and uh you know because you know
maybe you can go f4 now you can't oh
wow
checks maybe or just poor takes pawn
check yeah
i'm not playing this i'll take the draw
thank you yeah cheers yeah this is not
what i want to do see i mean that's
basically jordan's inner monologue there
simon he's basically saying the same
he's like oh i don't want to take this
draw but maybe i have to
i probably shouldn't have played this
opening if you didn't want to have
chances withdraw really because i mean
uh you could have gone for so much more
risky and he's gonna see it on the board
okay start of the checks
and uh yeah let's go back to the players
because we could well see a result any
moment now
unless jordan really wants to play with
fire it looks like he just has to allow
the position to repeat itself a series
of checks and a draw no way to escape
for the white king
and if it is a draw we will head to
blitz tie breaks in the other game still
going on the bar has actually gone up
for shakhriya and mamadiarov and if we
do have a winner in that matchup
then whoever wins will be the winner of
the match if that one too is a draw then
they too will play
thai breaks but is it looking good for
girl right now um it's looking yup still
a lot of life left but i would prefer
mamadara's position he's a pawn down but
he's got great uh kind of control for
that one pawn so dude on the defensive
all right and uh with this last move are
we still
heading towards the draw yeah it's
ivanka's move first of all that's a
diagonal check diagonal checks very
effective in general uh from queens and
you don't really want to push your pawn
up here to block this check if the white
pawn pushes forward the black rook come
down to the second rank with a check and
okay second time we've seen this
position you can see on anish's body
language he's ready to get out of here
and uh this is the second time we've
seen this position as well if we repeat
one more time it's a draw jordan just
double checking and
any moment now you will head to playoffs
any chance he'll go up here with his
king i think it's safe enough but
you don't
i don't think it's leading to a win so
why allow it yeah it is a draw ooh we're
having tie breaks today you guys yay oh
and what was that reaction from